i don't know it's like ad-libbed or
whatever that whole thing is absolutely
susan's ad-lib by the way the stars of
stranger things are definitely no
strangers to the art of improv this
video is chocked full of every ad-lib
improvised moment and mishap that were
kept in the final cut of season four
number one we know you're with us when
we say finally this time
it's gonna be different we've been
waiting for joyce and hopper to be
reunited ever since he got taken by the
russian government and clearly so were
winona ryder and david harbour according
to a tweet from the stranger things
writers that kiss was totally unscripted
winona and david added it in the day of
filming though they weren't instructed
to do so it seems like they knew the
fans needed that tender moment of
reconciliation between the two
characters
number two we've got a tearjerker here
in this intense sequence max bravely
entered vecna's mind lair for the second
time but unfortunately she didn't make
it out alive she collapses to the ground
bones broken eyes bleeding and has some
heartbreaking final lines clearly
emotions were running high when lucas
played by caleb mclaughlin improvised
the line where he calls out to his
sister erica for help it gives me chills
it was crazy
number three we're not crying you're
crying in this super emotional scene
eleven finally gets to hear how mike
really feels about her i love you for
exactly who you are
you're my superhero which gives her the
strength to break free from vechna's
grasp and put up a fight one thing you
might not know is that finn wolfhard was
incredibly nervous about that monologue
do this one more emotional do it more
confident we just kind of did it a few
different times he kept running through
the lines over and over in his head
trying to be as off book as he could by
the final take the duffer brothers gave
him permission to add whatever he wanted
to it like add whatever you want and so
that like you're my superhero line i
just like added
number four just more comedy gold from
joseph quinn in case you haven't noticed
we're big fans over here harrington's
got her
don't you think before
he definitely seems to have a knack for
coming up with brilliant in the moment
lines because of a tweet from a curious
fan we found out about this additional
improvised moment did he improvise the
don't you big boy at steve in the
campervan 2 just asking for a friend at
which the writers responded with a
simple yes do you think there's a chance
eddie could return from the upside down
give us your theories in the comments
number 5 we love a good stranger things
stunt charlie heaton and his co-star
eduardo franco had such a great time
working together eduardo was constantly
making charlie laugh with his random
hilarious unscripted one-liners the
scene where they're hitting golf balls
together on top of a cliff had some
strong comedic moments but one in
particular that was totally improvised
was charlie's dive through the van's
window she was just like as always
tension so i just decided to run and
jump through the window
number six that really is a funny word
man
charlie and eduardo are truly a comedic
dream team they had such great on-screen
chemistry that during many of their
scenes they were able to improv back and
forth with each other they spent about a
week filming this scene in argyle's van
bouncing lines off one another we got to
play around with this they give us a lot
of freedom to just riff off each other
number seven get ready to have your
heartstrings pulled joseph quinn made
quite the impression as the infamous
eddie munson we particularly love his
brotherly relationship with gayton
matarazzo's character dustin apparently
we weren't the only ones feeling the
love according to the writers of
stranger things the line i love you man
was completely improvised by quinn
gayton's natural response of i love you
too definitely solidified the intense
emotional ending
i love you dad
number eight only in a demo fight if we
try that again we'll never be able to
recreate it this is less of an
improvisation and more of a mistake that
was kept in the final cut
in this major scene the demogorgon takes
on a group of prisoners including our
beloved hopper the duffer brothers
really wanted to do this scene in one
shot but it proved to be too dangerous
luckily though they managed to get
something on film they didn't even know
they needed when the demogram throws
that guy and the bar collapses that's
actually a mistake but the duffer
brothers thought the shot looked so cool
and was captured so well that they
decided to keep it the way it was
number nine more like an attempted save
we're all familiar with the big shootout
scene that was done in one shot at the
buyer's house
obviously there are going to be some
great behind-the-scenes stories about it
apparently not only does the cast of
stranger things love a good improvised
moment on camera but off camera is just
as hilarious oh my god dude we just did
all that for nothing like your favorite
memory no no it's coming there's a
moment at the very end of the sequence
where they're about to finish the take
they just need the last soldier to step
inside the house and get shot but during
this take he never makes it in everyone
is pretty annoyed that they have to run
the sequence again but the stuntman
lightens up the mood with a bit of
improv a door gets kicked in and the
stunt guy's like
notably everyone else is standing around
in silent shock and then he got up and
he was like i think that went well
number 10 just some casual heartbreak
before you clock out the scene where
max's bones are breaking as lucas
watches on helplessly was the end of
quite a long day for the young actor he
was instructed to stare up and scream no
but due to the intense emotions of the
scene and overall exhaustion after the
fight with mason dye who plays jason he
stares up and yells max instead but then
when you see it all come together it's
like oh it was worth it in an interview
with we got this covered he talks a
little bit about his experience in that
moment i don't really like to rehearse
scenes like that because i want my
natural reaction i want to be real and
raw in the moment so i went off the cuff
just went for it of course as we did
more takes it got better and felt more
real and it helped that the duffer
brothers allowed me to improv and catch
the energy of the scene
number 11 let's crank that exhaustion up
to 11. we obviously can't forget these
iconic season 3 gems it wouldn't be
right to leave them out one thing we
knew about millie bobby brown is that
she's an insanely hard worker
she always gave 110 during the intense
fight scenes with daker montgomery's
character billy so much so that she
often blew out her voice on the day of
filming the scene where she throws billy
through a brick wall she was so
exhausted by the end that her collapse
into mike's arms was 100 real finn
wolfhard even breaks character for a
moment to look off at the director for
guidance
number 12 oh mike just tell her already
what i
want to say is
that
i just a moment we absolutely love from
season three was finn wolfhard's
improvised heart-to-heart scene with
millie bobby brown this moment of
rambling on in the attempt to get to an
i love you was all finn's brilliant
improvisation cbr.com recounts the
moment really well the spontaneity of
wolfhard's lines in this moment can be
noticed when brown tries her best not to
laugh at them ultimately her laughs were
kept in the final cut because her
reaction is true to her character the
cast of stranger things definitely has a
knack for knowing when to switch up a
line or add a bit of flair to a scene
what was your favorite improvised moment
of season four